[Musique]
ce choc promet été résolus mais je suis
très très proche de mes grands pères
puis je suis très très content pour eux
au bloc sarov
il était alors situé à quatre kilomètres
de l'état de new york
le camping domaine le dauphiné
d'hemmingford a été un des premiers à
recevoir les snowbirds en quarantaine au
mois de mars
sur les 200 places du gameplay ici en
une soixantaine qui sont occupées par
des snowbirds des gens qui vivent dans
le sud l'hiver et qui n'ont pas de
domicile fixe au québec depuis le début
de la pandémie seuls les snowbirds
avaient le droit de vivre dans les
campings du québec
le gouvernement autorise mercredi
l'ouverture de tous les terrains de la
province dès lundi prochain
[Musique]
crions marque le 15 juillet nouvelle
jetée corps mieux ou pis s était seul
dans le bureau
tous les axes entre 6 sur ce côté l'or
est offerte cette eau des snowbirds
manon es tu prête à interviewer au oui
oh oui j'ai retrouvé mes voisins écoute
ça fait c'est tellement wihr 2 j'ai
vraiment envie aux voûtes façon on ne
peut pas de problème garder la distance
qu'on a été réglo il ya vraiment pas de
problème pour le 6 pieds là il n'y a pas
de problème mystique on est étendue au
camping de dauphine est tous les
résidents aux 50 ans et plus plusieurs
sont donc à risque de complications
s'ils contractent le cône à virus mais
ça ne semble pas trop les inquiéter
l'ouverture peut pas dire que ça me fait
pas il en tient qu à moins que quelqu'un
s'approche trop à dire non respecter de
m s'ils veulent pas respecter où ils
font des rassemblements dans l'immédiat
je mettrai pas en danger mais
saisonniers n'ont plus l'eau est
normalement plus de 800000 snowboard
canadien migrent vers le sud chaque
année mais il n'est pas dit qu'il soit
aussi nombreux l'hiver prochain 99.95
des chances qu'on reste si on a
confiance que les français vont être
ouverts mais
on veut pas partir de parts qui tombait
malade aux états unis jean partir de la
fin octobre parce que j'ai aucun danger
la baule ou si on est comme ici on met
nos masques on ne leur en ai dit gel
polymère rocher wolmark labeaume et cela
même afrique si c'est la même chose
mais entre temps les beaux jours ne font
que commencer et pour les campeurs la
vraie saison commence lundi le kof vider
l'eau pour rester fa cup je pense que
ces sites à chacun de nous de se
respecter la face à solo
[Musique]